>>> IN OUR WORLD LEAD, PLATINUM
JUBILEE, A HISTORIC FOUR-DAY
CELEBRATION BEGINS TOMORROW FOR
QUEEN ELIZABETH II.
A PORTRAIT WAS RELEASED HONORING
HER 70 YEARS OF SERVICE.
MAX FOSTER LOOKS AT WHAT TO
EXPECT FROM THE ROYAL
CELEBRATION.
>> THE FINAL PREPARATIONS ARE
UNDER WAY TO CELEBRATE A MOMENT
OF HISTORY.
QUEEN ELIZABETH, THE FIRST
BRITISH ROYAL TO CELEBRATE A
PLATINUM JUBILEE, COMMEMORATING
70 YEARS OF SERVICE.
THE LINEUP INCLUDES A BIRTHDAY
PARADE, WITH GUN SALUTES AND THE
LIGHTING OF BEACONS ACROSS THE
COMMONWEALTH.
A THANKSGIVING SERVICE, A PALACE
CONCERT, A PLATINUM PAGEANT.
12 MILLION PEOPLE ACROSS THE UK
ARE SET TO ATTEND STREET PARTIES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> IT'S A HUGE MILESTONE.
VERY HARD WORKING LADY.
>> SAME KIND OF FEELING AS THE
WEDDINGS.
JUST EVERYBODY IS HAPPY AND YOU
WANT TO MAKE FRIENDS AND SAY HI
AND SMILE.
>> I SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MA'AM.
AND GOD SAVE THE QUEEN.
>> EVENTS GET STARTED ON
THURSDAY, WITH THE TROUPING OF
THE COLOR WHICH HAS MARKED THE
OFFICIAL BIRTHDAY OF THE BRITISH
SOVEREIGN FOR MORE THAN 260
YEARS.
ALL THE POMP AND PAGEANTRY THAT
1,200 MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY,
HUNDREDS OF ARMY MUSICIANS, AND
AROUND 240 HORSES CAN MUSTER.
ON SUNDAY, THE GOLD STATE COACH
WILL MAKE ITS FIRST APPEARANCE
IN DECADES, LEADING A PROCESSION
OF PERFORMERS AND PERSONALITIES.
PRINCE CHARLES WILL STEP IN WHEN
HIS MOTHER FEELS UNABLE TO MAKE
AN EVENT.
WHAT'S ALWAYS MOST TELLING ABOUT
THESE OCCASIONS IS THE BALCONY
APPEARANCE.
IT'S USED TO PROJECT THE MODERN
FACE OF BRITISH MONARCHY.
IN 2002, WE SAW THE ENTIRE
EXTENDED FAMILY.
IN 2012, IT WAS STRIPPED RIGHT
BACK TO ITS CORE TO REFLECT THE
MORE AUSTERE TIMES.
AND THIS YEAR, IT'S WORKING
ROYALS ONLY.
SO THAT MEANS YOU WON'T SEE
PRINCE ANDREW OR PRINCE HARRY
WITH MEGHAN.
THEY'RE ALL OFF THE LIST.
THE SUSSEXS ARE INVITED AND WILL
APPEAR, POSSIBLY WITH THEIR TWO
CHILDREN DURING EVENTS.
THE WORLD WILL BE LOOKING
CLOSELY AT THEIR BODY LANGUAGE
AS THEY INTERACT WITH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY FOLLOWING
THAT RIFT.
IT WILL BE QUITE SOMETHING,
JAKE, I HAVE TO SAY, TO SEE THE
SUSSEXES IN THE ROYAL FOLD ONCE
AGAIN.
I HAVE TO SAY, DOWN HERE, PEOPLE
CAMPING OUT READY FOR THE BIG
MOMENT, MANY ROYAL FANS, MANY
JUST WANTING TO COME ALONG, HAVE
A PARTY, AND CELEBRATE AFTER
SOME TOUGH FEW YEARS FOR
EVERYONE.
REALLY, THOUGH, THE FOCUS IS ON
THE QUEEN ALL THOSE YEARS OF
SERVICE.
TH